ربوطات ذكيه ومفعمه بالحيويه كانت في
استقبال زوار معرض مؤتمر الروبوتات
العالمي في بيتين في نسخته الثامنه لم
يفوت الزوار تسجيل لحظات تعبيريه لروبوتات
يشبه بعضها شخصيات تاريخيه صينيه اضحت
الروبوتات تحاكي تعبيرات الوجوه البشريه
بشكل اكثر واقعيه
من خلال احدث جيل لدينا من المحركات
الفائقه يمكن لروبوتاتنا ان توحد التحكم
في كل مفصل من مفاصلها بحيث تكون حركاتها
طبيعيه جدا
متحركه المعروضه للروبوتات بشره تشبه بشره
الانسان
ميراث وجوه ومفاصل تسمح لها بالقيام
بحركات مرنه
هذا الصف من الوجوه الاليه ينسخ بدقه طرفه
العين وغمزها والايماء بالراس
تعتمد تعابير الوجه على المعلومات
البيولوجيه التي جمعت من الوجوه البشريه
وتعد حركه روبوتات انعكاسا لافعال الانسان
التي صورت وحللت بالذكاء الاصطناعي حازت
الروبوتات الشبيهه بالانسان ثناء بعض صور
المعرض
اعتقد ان الروبوتات تبدو حقيقيه جدا بما
في ذلك اعينها وبعض حركات ملامحها فضلا عن
نعومه حركات اليد في المستقبل اعتقد ان
هذه الروبوتات ستحل ببطء محل البشر للقيام
ببعض الاعمال واذا استخدمناها جيدا فانها
ستساعدنا بالتاكيد على تحسين الانتاجيه
بمزيد من الكفاءه
مؤتمر روبوتات العالمي تنظمه الحكومه
الشعبيه لبلديه بيجين ووزاره الصناعه
وتكنولوجيا المعلومات الصينيه وتشارك فيه
اكثر من 160 شركه محليه واجنبيه يعد
المؤتمر فرصه لشركات التكنولوجيا الصينيه
لعرض اخر منتجاتها من الروبوتات الموجهه
لمجالات كالتصنيع والطب والتعليم والزراعه
والخدمات وحتى الرفقه والتسليه والالعاب
شركه تقنيه مقرها
تعرض روبوتات من ذوات الاربع مستوحاه من
الكلاب تستخدم لمرافقه الاسره والدوريه
الصناعيه
والانقاذ من الحرائق اضحت هذه الروبوتات
رشيقه ومطوعه بفضل الذكاء الاصطناعي
والتطورات التقنيه الاخرى